[Musique]
mercredi 14 mars devant les grilles du
conseil constitutionnel en plein centre
de paris
une voiture blindée aux vitres fumées
fait son apparition
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour ces vraiment visible
autrement je viendrai pas là après avoir
entretenu le suspense durant plusieurs
mois
jean-marie le pen vient enfin déposer
ses 500 signatures des maires il devient
officiellement candidat à l'élection
présidentielle
à la sortie jean marie le pen improvise
une conférence de presse et donne tout
de suite le ton du début de sa campagne
535 signature cette année encore il n'y
aura de grandes surprises et beaucoup de
grincements de dents le soir du premier
tour
une annonce qui soulage ses
sympathisants mais attise la colère de
ses opposants
[Applaudissements]
les
[Musique]
certains le disent politiquement
affaibli il se serait paraît-il assagi
d'autres sous entendent qu'il est
aujourd'hui plus fréquentable pour ses
détracteurs jean marie le pen reste un
provocateur un manipulateur l'homme des
dérapages racistes et xénophobes
le leader du front national est
aujourd'hui l'un des quatre candidats
susceptibles d'accéder au second tour de
l'élection présidentielle
alors est-il devenu un homme politique
comme les autres il est en quête de
respectabilité at-il vraiment atteint
son objectif session
est-ce qu'on s'arrêtait
[Musique]
nous avons passé trois mois avec lui
dans les coulisses de sa dernière
campagne pour mieux comprendre quel est
le vrai visage de jean marie le pen
[Musique]
ce matin nous avons rendez vous avec
jean marie le pen devant le domicile de
son épouse à rueil malmaison c'est là
qu'il vit toute l'année
chauffeur valises et garde du corps
aujourd'hui nous partons en voyage pour
le trajet il a accepté que nous montions
avec lui dans sa voiture blindée
[Musique]
jean marie le pen va exercer son seul
mandat d'élu celui de député européen
direction bruxelles avec son assistante
parlementaire depuis la veille
il est sous escorte policière comme les
candidats exposés seulement voilà alors
que la campagne bat son plein jean marie
le pen se passerait bien de ce petit
voyage à bruxelles mais il a une très
bonne raison d'y aller
[Musique]
nous avons mais demain une séance de
vote
alors c'est sûr ce vote sont très
importantes parce que ce sont elles qui
qualifie en quelque sorte la présence
qui prouvent la présence du député à au
parlement donc obligation d'y être
pardon donc obligation de l obligation d
aide quand on n'y est pas on perd une
partie importante de la débilité
parlementaire une indemnité qui s'élève
tout de même à 6800 91 euros brut par
mois
nous profitons alors du trajet pour
évoquer les souvenirs de celui qui a
créé il ya 35 ans le front national
qu'est ce qui vous plaît encore
aujourd'hui dans ce militantisme et van
son
c'est ma vie
ma vie j'en ai fait les chansons à
cessieu sursaut de parier à quai ou mon
voisin de la trinité sur mer un copain
il chante moi maintenant dommage mais
oui le cetim a vite politique est jugée
je suis tombé dans la politique rentre
en indochine chanterelle à deux chiffres
au sens en octobre à 55,3 m aux trois
mois après j'ai débuté il vous n'avez
jamais bien du la fois non
j'ai toujours eu
désespoir en politique est une sottise
absolue ont fait le travail bibi bientôt
on arrive là dont 500 m
et en même temps le soleil
les seuils des bips soleil baby soleil
tu ressens qui les choses ne seraient
que ce qu'elles sont c'est quand même
donné bien sympathique de soleil place
on sort de là des dons j'ai pas
l'habitude de sortir par la gauche quand
jean marie le pen fait son entrée dans
une station service
ça ne passe évidemment pas inaperçu
je suis chauffeur falot à bon excusez
moi qu'est ce que vous pensez à l'heure
actuelle de tout ce qui se passe avec
les ségolène royal s'est reposé il c'est
une occupation totale général il occupe
le terrain complètement yarakh pour eux
et pendant ce temps là on parle pas des
autres c'est une technique d'occupation
des sols la bonne continuation vous
à vous aussi vous voulez bien qu'elle a
coiffe un peu quel point à 44 tonnes au
frigo bonne route
au revoir notre jour moi je viens de
voir
c'est aussi récent will change antilles
généralement pas l'air comme ça elle
multiplie net aujourd'hui à vous merci
dame âgée
[Musique]
le parlement européen situé en plein
coeur de bruxelles
c'est ici que 80% des lois appliquées en
france ont voté pour toucher son salaire
de député jean marie le pen doit se
rendre ici dans l'hémicycle deux fois
par mois
jean-marie le pen et député européen
depuis 22 ans
c'est le seul mandat qu'il conserve
précieusement nous le suivrons dans son
bureau de parlementaires situé au 1er
étage un bureau étrangement vide où les
dossiers brillent par leur absence
tant dans les armoires que sur les
étagères je vois des séances et à
strasbourg
aujourd'hui il a une tâche
supplémentaire à remplir il ne se rend
pas dans l'hémicycle mais à une autre
réunion
il s'agit de la commission du commerce
international celle où l'on vote les
accords commerciaux de l'europe avec le
monde entier
ce matin elle doit élire son nouveau
président est jean marie le pen va
exceptionnellement présidé la séance
je suis à l'heure un privilège accordé
aux plus vieux députés je suis non
seulement le doyen d'âge mais je suis le
plus ancien député certainement parce
que j'ai débuté depuis 22 ans
la commission qui se dopent les
anciennes moi je marie le pen semble un
peu perdu une assistante s'en aperçoit
et lui indique la place qu'il doit
occuper
une chose est sûre jean marie le pen n'a
pas l'air très familier avec le
protocole mieux alors il va demander
l'assistance d'un membre du parlement
je pense assistant ciel est d'accord
problème avec moi s'il n'y a pas finit
pas de grandir car on fait par la nation
à vrai dire tout cela ne semble pas
vraiment le passionné à la tête de cette
commission ça vous fait lois physiques
mais bluey pas je n'ai pas rêver tous
les matins embrasant d'être à jour de
présider la commission du commerce
international du parlement européen
parmi les députés la présence de jean
marie le pen suscite l'étonnement
j'ai joué dans les commissions il n'est
jamais là jamais je les ai vus partie
une seule commission
le fait que vous soyez à ça le fait
venir il faudrait venir à chaque
commission ça le ferait participer aux
travaux des parlementaires du commun
dont on n'a pas vu écouté
objectivement je ne les ai pas vus
depuis
plus humide jamais en publicité
bon allez depuis
depuis
du monde car il advenir
de 300 bons mais la seule chose que je
sais que dans quelques minutes on verra
bien et c'est précisément ce qu'il va se
passer
séance est ouverte selon procéder
d'abord à l'élection du président y at
il une autre candidature que celle de
monsieur markov
je vois qu'il n'y a pas d'autre candidat
ni d'autres oppositions je considère
donc comme monsieur markov est élu par
acclamation je vais vous céder la place
après avoir cédé son siège au nouveau
président jean marie le pen reste dans
la salle une petite demi-heure puis s'en
va il faut dire qu'à paris une autre
présidence l'intéressent beaucoup plus
[Musique]
exo mémoire hommage et il ya toujours
saint cloud en banlieue parisienne c'est
ici dans ce bâtiment que l'on appelle le
paquebot que se trouve le siège du front
national depuis quelques semaines tous
les lundis matin jean marie le pen se
déplace en personne pour présider une
réunion de campagne
pour les cadres du parti se réunissent
afin de préparer les meetings politiques
et les rendez vous médiatique du
candidat
d'habitude ces réunions se déroulent à
huis clos mais exceptionnellement ce
matin nous avons été autorisés à un film
et une partie une occasion pour nous de
pénétrer au coeur même du dispositif de
campagne
un des postes clés et tenus par sa fille
marine
c'est elle qui veut modifier l'image de
son père pour la rendre plus respectable
sur france inter il y avait un reportage
sur sur marine oui voulait entendu et
corinne lepage alors que tu étais très
sympathique très sympathique voilà qu'on
peut serrer la main avant les c'est
normal ben non parce qu'elle a dit je ne
serai pas la main monsieur la dynamique
est pas demain c'est la guille et la
guille elle sert la main jamais la main
parce qu'elle ne veut pas qu'il existe
des photos d'elle en train de serrer la
main à un adversaire politique la
vieille dame à faire ça peut faire la
bise
le rappel de cet épisode assez sharks en
écho martinez la plaie à l'oreille ne
l'appelez pas je veux bien gardés de la
vie vous êtes la schtroumpfette de la
politique je ne suis pas assez qu'on
fait de jeu ne voulait plus pour la
pierre mais qu'elle était
on va écouter allons commencer la
réunion démarre nous espérions obtenir
quelques indiscrétions de la stratégie
de campagne nous allons vite être déçus
de lumière remettre des allogènes à part
un petit problème dans pool au siège du
fn nous n'apprendrons rien de crues les
jours et quand bien l'ordre du jour
nous sommes priés de quitter les lieux
en réalité pour mieux comprendre comment
jean marie le pen mène sa campagne il
faut le suivre dans ses déplacements en
province
fin janvier nous sommes à yvetot en
normandie au milieu d'un terrain vague
un gymnase transformé pour l'occasion en
salle de réception car le front national
en ce début de campagne n'organise pas
des meetings non mais des déjeuner
patriotique
ce jour-là 800 militants réserver leur
place est pour eux l'occasion de
rencontrer leur idole jean marie le pen
un culte de la personnalité que le front
national c'est très bien exploiter et
entretenir les t-shirts le pen président
qui clignote donc on peut les voir ici
il ya un modèle femme un modèle enfant
est un modèle homme l'a ensuite nous
avons des casquettes lumineuse aussi en
fait y'a un petit bouton
bien sûr on l'éteint où on allait on va
voir lé nounours alors ça c'est le
produit qui connaît le nounours le pen
c'est la mascotte du militant dans ces
déjeuners ces petits gadgets font un
malheur 800 personnes aujourd'hui je
pense que oui on va parvenir à la grand
chose les personnes en général
d'hachette au minimum avoir deux voire
trois objets au minimum jeu mais en
général il ya très très peu de personnes
qui repartent sans rien évidemment le
visage du leader est omniprésent il est
accroché sur tous les murs mais pas
seulement
alors là on en a fait une chose assez
original c'est que nous avons un set de
table mais et de reprendre sous
l'assiette voyez il ya marqué le grand
banquet patriotique et les gens vont
l'amener vous allez voir ça va durer au
moins 1h ou 1h30 vont faire la queue
pour avoir la dédicace du président ils
vont encadrer ensuite ce document qui
est un document prévoyait qu'ils étaient
beaux pendant ce temps là à l'extérieur
les gros bras du service de sécurité du
front national se positionne pour
contrôler et toutes les issues
aujourd'hui 35 hommes sont
réquisitionnés
[Musique]
car à chaque déplacement de jean marie
le pen le front national redoutent les
débordements d'opposants monsieur le pen
arrive pas vous ah ça fait partie de la
sécurité on ne dit pas par où il ya
toujours deux ou trois quatre chemins
possibles mais on dit ville que jamais
celui qu'il va utiliser c'est au dernier
moment en rapport avec notre service de
sécurité et la gendarmerie qu'il prend
le chemin qui correspond le mieux à sa
sécurité
il ya un véritable danger pour véritable
danger vous savez il suffit de d'une
personne ou deux qui jette un caillou
qui cherchent à des déséquilibrés on l'a
vu partout à l'extérieur de la salle il
y as foule chacun dû payer 15 euros pour
déjeuner et assister au discours de jean
marie le pen 13 heures 30 le cortège
arrive enfin
monsieur le président trazié pas de
routes pas excellent excellente
à l'intérieur de la salle l'ambiance est
surchauffée les militants lui réserve un
accueil de star
[Musique]
l'accord
pendant que les convives boivent leur
café jean marie le pen fait un rapide
discours d'une demi-heure naturelle afin
que les pages à écrire l'histoire de
france ne soit pas la dernière danse et
déjeuner patriotique
le discours de jean marie le pen ce
n'est en fait que le or devant juste
après il passe entre les tables et
improvise un spectacle de chansonniers
vous avez une chance extraordinaire
c'est celle de me voir quand on voit
rarement sur les antennes sur les écoles
télévision seulement moi j'ai moins
besoin créé votre front moi je suis
comme nous aurons genre on ne voit
jamais et pourtant on sait qui des da et
il suffit qu'on entende haga l'autre
cheval ou qu'on voit une ombre passé en
face de la lune on se dit il doit être
par la zorro et surtout si on voit un
quelqu'un se frotter les faits ce qui
vient de se les faire voter ont été
dépassés par les militants apprécié
l'exercice de style pour amuser la
galerie jean marie le pen ne ménage pas
ses efforts au grand charitable qui nous
gouvernent de passer devant la
télévision
et si son patient au moins trois fois
ils sont allés au val de grâce tous les
ministres président toute la classe
politique en prend pour son grade de
jacques chirac à ségolène royal une
femme est alors on m'a dit martin non en
marquer non
non ségolène elle a été au cabinet de
françois mitterrand ce qui est aussi si
j'ose dire une bonne introduction et
puis il interpréter pendant que son mari
est sur le devant de la scène son épouse
jany elle est au fond de la salle
elle signe des autographes je me calme
en attendant ces beaux souvenirs
ensemble ils vont faire les choses et
affectueuse c'est pas des messages
d'affection un peu d'amitié suivie par
un déjeuner patriotique ans a devancé le
passionnant pour moi j'ai toujours envie
de les côtés de bruit mais n'empêche
quelques femmes et puis
du coup les gens me connaissent mieux
aussi c'est important qu'elle est tout
seul mais qui sait si jamais il y avait
un rôle à tenir alors au plus haut
niveau
contact avec les rails pour ressortir
que l'on déroge la femme le spectacle se
termine inévitablement musique et c'est
jean marie le pen qui donne le ton si
vous voulez bien nous allons chanter
ensemble notre hymne national la
marseillaise
[Musique]
après la marseillaise
les militants vont pouvoir approcher
leur idole
pendant deux heures et demie jean marie
le pen va signer des sets de table
et c'est comme ça dans tous lés déjeuner
patriotique
les militants repartent gonflé à bloc
par l'homme et ses idées
parce que si ce côté comme un saint vous
le connaissez pas une couleur seul et
sans arrêt on le voit la télé payante
il est pas dans son état et de son
élément et venez chez lui venaient eux
dans des endroits où il est rien vous
allez voir c'est si c'est un apôtre
aussi il est mieux que l'abbé pierre je
pense que le pen représente tout à fait
là la valeur de la france sa culture
les cultures qu'on a perdu
la famille le chemin
éducation un toutes ces choses qui sont
à des années
chaude aux socialistes de droite ont à
peine chirac et compagnie nous ont
descendu au 36e rang mondial alors vous
étiez au quatrième rang nous avons
l'intention non c'est long de remonter
la pente et si possible d'aller plus
avant mais quand on est à tous droite à
sortir des tâches est bien là où la
presse les médias disent à qui venait
affoler le monde attend les chiffres des
journées l'énergie les mines et depuis
trois quêtes il était juste qu'ils aient
voulu dire qu au lieu d'agiter qu'est ce
qu'on attend de l'état
il a toujours dit il à tous aujourd'hui
c'est que personne ne dit encore
aujourd'hui à s'il vous plaît madame je
vous connais pas les attendait
dès qu'elle pioche le piège venir la
vérité va obliger la vérité que c'est
monsieur me trouble au contraire mais
faire la bretagne à nos mères nos mails
et le système dans lequel nous vivons
qu'il n'ya pas plus raciste connu
puisqu'il prend t-il et jours à longueur
de journée le racisme anti français
ah ça c'est l'heure ça c'est normal à
bercy village mais pas la guerre civile
aujourd'hui on appris samedi minimum et
2005 et carros a mis le doigt sur des à
coups de feu vert au projet des
migrations nostalgie des valeurs perdues
décadence de la france
des thèmes que les militants reprennent
à leur compte en bon ambassadeur de
leurs leaders
il repart sous les applaudissements mais
ça ne va pas durer pour quitter le
meeting il devra passer sous les injures
d'une vingtaine d'opposants
[Musique]
une vue imprenable sur paris
nous sommes sur les hauteurs de saint
cloud grille en fer forgé portail
magistral c'est l'entrée du parc de
montretout une des résidences les plus
huppés de la banlieue chic de paris
au bout de cette année une somptueuse
bâtisse une propriété estimée à plus de
6 millions d'euros
jean-marie le pen en a hérité en 1976
depuis cette époque il vit comme un
grand bourgeois et ne refusent jamais
aux journalistes une petite visite de
son hôtel particulier
l'occasion pour lui de montrer qu'il est
un homme respectable et cultivé il ya
beaucoup d'objets de maire parce que je
suis un marin d'origine est ce que
scaphandrier c'est un soutien jumelles
de croiseurs français et qui étaient à
l'époque l'instrument de surveillance
avant les radars les tous les
instruments plus moderne et moi ça me
sert à regarder à regarder paris et ici
il ya une partie de la bibliothèque à
laquelle je tiens beaucoup
parce que c'est la bibliothèque de mon
enfance et de mon adolescence
les trois mousquetaires le comte de
monte cristo sont des choses qui m'ont
marqué est un enfant m'a par exemple
c'est une collection de romans policiers
ça mais cette année grèce à maigret
l'autre alors ça c'est à vivre assez
rare parce que c'est un livre un
dictionnaire français breton il ya un
mot kg et qui est très intéressant noyer
qui est relatif à mon nom eri eh oui
du stic les caisses qui est dit un autre
mois la chef qui tient le premier rang
peine
il possède aussi une grande collection
de tableaux de plusieurs époques de
plusieurs styles mais toujours avec le
même modèle enfin c'est mon portrait par
eux il y à 15,9 qui est le le président
de l'académie de peinture de moscou
et puis ça c'est le dernier tableau qui
m'a été offert le connaissez non à ben
non c'est jean marie le pen en corsaire
le peintre des tableaux qui ont envahi
sa résidence et que l'on retrouve jusque
dans son secrétariat
c'est là la chapelle et arrière alors
c'est ici c'est assez lepéniste comme
des corps sains comme vous voulez
constaté sent quand même une petite
exception c'est c'est ce n'est pas moi
qui ait fait cela c'est se sont
dégradées les gauchistes c'est moi avec
mon mon premier petit fils
la trinité voyez puis un peu partout des
le voilà vous que vous collectionnez c
s'établit donc je collectionne pas en
les offres d'habitude voilà c'est pour
ça la tradition beau je l'aimais je
trouve qu'ils sont pas mis là c'est
particulier ça c'est une offre un jour
de victoire électorale ça en fait
jean-marie le pen travail beaucoup plus
souvent dans sa villa qu'au siège du
front national comme vous voulez savoir
quoi ils travaillent de rentrer ses
conseillers comment ils travaillent s'il
ya automatiquement à un droit donc à
entreprendre en quelque sorte celui
qu'il entreprend de la preuve
aujourd'hui il a organisé un déjeuner
d'experts sur les problèmes économiques
la préférence nationale mais c'était en
référence aux régimes spéciaux
entre la poire et le fromage on parle
économie gestion et création
d'entreprise des sujets sur lesquels
jean marie le pen semble avoir un
certain retard c'est difficile le but de
cette réunion qui se passe et bien c'est
une commission commission d'études
économiques et sociales voilà on prépare
des débats sur les sujets de l'économie
en particulier où les drg j'ai là le
plus ancien livre l'économique du front
national qui est la droite et démocratie
économique c'est c'était 1973 et c'est
grâce à 33 ans ça marche encore avec
vous nous présenter les personnes qui
sont autour de la table
oh non
non non non ce sont des experts d'accord
merci
et une fois de plus nous sommes priés de
quitter les lieux
jean-marie le pen n'aime pas qu'on entre
dans le détail de ces réunions
en revanche il aime beaucoup se montrer
avec ses chiens
il aime aussi donner l'image d'un chef
de famille qui a réussi à rassembler
sous le même toit enfants et
petits-enfants
j'ai une fille qui habite au au deuxième
et puis marine habito s'est fait à l'oft
dans les allées et comment les chambres
de personnel des communs il ya plus de
personnel non il ya mes filles
alors ça c'est le l'entraînement au
football de mai 2010 fils est peut-être
devenu une petite fille aussi je ne sais
pas l'air si elle joue au football vous
avez combien de petits enfants 9 9 9
alors ce bruit quand je suis ici me fait
penser aux brisants des tropiques et
quand je suis dans les tropiques
il me fait penser à l'autre de
l'intimité de jean marie le pen nous
n'en saurons pas plus la visite aura
duré à peine une demi-heure toujours
sous le contrôle de son directeur de la
communication
et là c'est la porte
à bientôt
cette image de grand père tranquille
jean marie le pen ne la soigne pas
seulement devant notre caméra
ce jour-là il est l'invité d'une
émission politique sur france 24
la nouvelle chaîne d'info international
du service public
les femmes l'homme est un pro des médias
[Musique]
face aux journalistes jean marie le pen
arrive les mains dans les poches
il n'a pas une note sur lui le trac il
semble ne pas connaître en vue de la rue
mais on vous voit de la rue vous avez
des vitres blindées ça va oui l épreuve
des 12,7
ça va avec le nom de soleure c'est bon
il doit vous aimez les enfants peuvent
générer
[Musique]
bonsoir merci
l'homme à la pêche il a aussi la
répartie facile résidentiel ce soir je
reçois jean marie le pen bonsoir bonsoir
alors est ce que vous croyez à
l'hypothèse de la candidature chirac
parce qu'on vous prête des dons
prémonitoire ce gentil non non ça gentil
s'est fait ma part féminine
vous avez une part féminine et mérite
que peut-être vous avez vous même une
petite part masculine très peu travers
le reconnaître mais moi je te comme tout
le monde j'ai une petite part de
féminité et moi c'est probablement en
intuition et c'est peut-être à la
télévision que l'image du leader
frontiste a le plus changé
le type qui castagne une élue socialiste
qui dit de référence crématoire c'est
fini il est en quête de respectabilité
comme si le 2000 le 21 avril 2002
l'avait en quelque sorte légitimé aux
yeux des français alors ça c'est vrai
quand il dit que les français ont un
autre regard sur lui mais lui aussi
grâce à mon avis à sa fille marine
il est un peu plus je pense qui se mord
la langue je pense que sa fille ait
contribué à le hâle adoucir jeudi à
l'ats s'agir peut-être on n'est pas
froid merci à bientôt
voire plus
alors jean marie le pen s'est il
vraiment assagie
vous allez voir que même s'il fait des
efforts son naturel revient vite au
galop
en plein coeur de la picardie au milieu
de ce champ un cimetière et pas
n'importe lequel
ici sont enterrés des milliers de
combattants chinois venus apporter leur
aide aux soldats français de la première
guerre mondiale
c'est le seul cimetière chinois en
france en temps normal le lieu reçoit
peu de visiteurs mais ce jour là à
l'entrée du cimetière il ya foule
[Musique]
non
à 11 heures précises
un cortège de limousines fait son
apparition attention messieurs
[Musique]
militant du front national et
journalistes se pressent tout le monde
est curieux de savoir ce que jean marie
le pen vient faire ici
[Musique]
en fait c'est sa réaction au voyage de
ségolène royal en chine symbolique
voulait accorder des mois je n'ai pas
l'occasion n'ayant pas les avions du
glam à ma disposition je ne peux pas
aller en chine
alors je viens rendre hommage aux
chinois surtout ceux qui sont dans la
terre de france en cette terre de la
somme dont vous savez qu'elle contient
tant et tant de morts aussi bien de
britanniques que françaises
et bien je vous j'ai voulu faire un
petit geste en leur faveur
la campagne but et c'est à vous de
l'établir je pense que vous ne manquez
pas de finesse
vous trouverez certainement c'est un
drôle d'endroit français laurent que ça
se passe au niveau 6 s'il était ailleurs
on irait ailleurs si c'était à menton et
et inventons mais ses fans ouailles
élevé à leur envier à noyal
il va se recueillir dans les allées du
cimetière puis allume selon la tradition
bouddhiste ou des bâtons d'encens
[Musique]
les chinois denoyelle certainement à
cent lieues de penser qu'on viendrait un
jour leur rendre visite
le moment est solennel dégoûté jeu
quelques instants souvenir de ces prêts
de milliers de schiste milliers de
chinois qui est ici enterré si loin de
ça de sa terre patrie depuis si
longtemps
j'ai beau merci un proverbe qui le
touche particulièrement vous en tant que
candidat on ne sait pas ne vient pas à
l'esprit comme ça mais j'en trouverai
certainement seulement voilà la
cérémonie est troublé par la venue d'une
maire de la commune qui refuse de serrer
la main de jean marie le pen sur mer
vous accueille aujourd'hui par politesse
républicaine
et bien c'est très bien ainsi d'habitude
ce cimetière chinois ou j'accueille
l'ambassadeur de chine populaire en
france je l'accueille au nom de la
france avec monde est cher simplement
aujourd'hui je voudrais par mon
sentiment vous êtes dans ma commune très
bien monsieur comme tout citoyen
français très bien monsieur a bien assez
simplement mais bien sûr je ne suis pas
l'ambassadeur de chine communiste
monsieur le maire est ce que vous avez
apporté votre signature
jean-marie le pen non voyons j'étais
sollicité je n'apporte aucune signature
monsieur le maire que ce soit de vous
avez refusé de serrer la main que jean
marie le pen
j'estime que je n'ai pas le serrer la
main
paralysé d'un clown je connais
particulièrement ce sens tiers et la
région ici je vais vous dire c'est que
lorsque les chinois étaient là il était
redouté par la population la population
avait des préjugés à leur égard à ces
possibles soit vous estimez cette
attitude je ne sais pas vous savez je ne
juge pas les gens du siècle dernier mois
le jeu comprend que les étrangers
puissent se rendre sur ce qu'ils avaient
sans doute les yeux ne parlais
pas la langue du pays et ceux ci
devaient peux te paraît peut-être
inquiétant c'est n'en est toujours
inquiété par l'inconnu vous savez
cette visite doit être absolument
relayées dans la presse
alors avant de partir il se prête
volontiers aux exigences des
photographes jean marie le pen veut
réaffirmer ici son nationalisme
traditionnel à cet événement il va
rajouter la petite touche le pen le
journaliste qui demandait un proverbe
dit il je boot est né par nos goûters
n'est pas là un français vivant un
français vivant vaut mieux cacher nos
mamans c'est un proverbe fabriquer
il faut toujours vous expliquer des
choses toujours une dernière déclaration
en forme de provocation
cela fait 20 ans qu'il utilise ces
méthodes pour faire parler de lui dans
les médias
[Musique]
quelques jours plus tard devant l'entrée
d'une chaîne de télévision
la voiture n'est même pas arrêté que
jean marie le pen bangui
ce matin il a l'air contrarié il arrive
sans dire un mot sans saluer quiconque
il connaît les lieux ils filent
directement maquillage et là encore
peindre
direction le studio au pas de course
nous le suivons avec notre caméra pas
continuer comme ça vous voulez que bon
d'accord
[Musique]
avant d'entrer sur le plateau jean marie
le pen trépigne d'impatience
mais pourquoi est-il donc en colère nous
allons vite le comprendre
notre invité ce matin sommes à j moins
90 3 mois surtout jours avant le premier
tour d'élections précédentes nous allons
parler
cette élection est votre réaction à ce
qu'on a appris ce matin la mort de
l'abbé pierre il avait 94 ans sic
transit 94 ans soit la disparition de
cet air visiblement il n'est pas venu
ici pour parler de la mort de l'abbé
pierre
s'il est en colère c'est qu'il a un
petit compte à régler avec la chaîne
habituée des dithyrambes célèbre sauf
quand il s'agit de façon signature oui
alors justement la semaine petit bison
point fr petites maisons en bois parce
que le journaliste qui était à l'antenne
hier soir a déclaré que je refaisais le
coup de 2002 avec les signatures de
votre confrère suggérer c'est que dans
le fond je les ai et je fais semblant de
ne pas les avoir sur votre antenne
j'espère que votre gré la mise au point
est fait jean marie le pen lance le
feuilleton des 500 signatures qui va
durer plus d'un mois bénéficier les
quatre grands partis
on va parler à la sortie du plateau
l'homme se sent beaucoup plus léger
juste un petit mot sur ses patients tu
sais pas vous devriez trouver un petit
peu tendu tant attendu non je me serais
le moi j'ai dit ce que j'avais à dire
vie des victimes qu fort et je le dis
voilà et le petit café c'est l'occasion
pour jean marie le pen en remettre une
couche cette fois à la directrice de la
chaîne le problème c'est faire accoucher
passage vous refais le faire à quelqu'un
j'ai dû m'en dire c'est tellement pas
forcément ce que j'ai à faire antoine
les mêmes valeurs morales
grand palais de lille
c'est le rendez vous majeur de la
campagne du front national jean marie le
pen doit annoncer sans programme
économique
nous avons découvert qu'ils gèrent en
coulisses les shows du leader du fn une
mise en scène digne des plus grands
spectacles dans la salle de congrés une
femme suit de près tous les préparatifs
en blouson rouge c'est yann le pen la
fille aînée du président si sa soeur
marines exposant les médias yann vit
dans l'ombre de son père elle n'accepte
que très rarement de parler aux
journalistes
et pourtant elle a un rôle essentiel
c'est elle qui gère la propagande du
front national les affiches s'il m'en
charge s'ils temps en temps les gadgets
votre équipe qui avons un peu sur les
gadgets des bbr nac s'illumine et sur
qui s'allume et machin c'est mon truc
c'est notre truc
c'est elle aussi qui a en charge les
films de la campagne comme celui ci qui
sera présenté en avant première aux
militants le lendemain un film réalisé
en images de synthèse qui montre des
avions de chasse portant le logo du
front national
existe pas cet avion pour la roche
dessinée nous nos avions ne causera 9 à
3 1
et comme par hasard ces avions partent à
l'assaut de l'elysée
tout un symbole
[Musique]
côté fonctions je pense que la garden
party ça me branche pas bien organisé ça
mais je pense que j'organiserai sûrement
encore je suis pas peut-être lequel des
déplacements n'en sais rien j'aimerais
bien avoir organisé des trucs plus
grande ampleur quoi les gros défis nous
avons organisé le défilé du 14 juillet
retour à la réalité
yann le pen organise les meetings du
front national depuis une vingtaine
d'années si elle a rejoint le parti ce
n'est pas totalement le fruit du hasard
pourquoi rejoindre aventure familiale
pour deux choses 1 par choix par amour
par plaisir de un petit peu par
obligation aussi parce qu'ayant ayant
essayé plusieurs métiers
j'ai eu quand même pas mal de problèmes
voilà fait juste et la fille le pen
c'est vrai que je souk le mèdes que ce
soit en prenant des appartements quand
j'ai essayé de monter ma propre boîte
puisque j'en ai monté une c'est vrai que
c'est pas évident donc c'est vrai qu'il
ya un petit peu les deux je pense que
peut-être j'aurais rejoint quand même
mais certains moments j'aurais peut-être
aimé faire ce que je fais me la mets
ailleurs et c'est ce qui s'appelle le
pen c'est un handicap comme ça votre
avis vous savez très bien bien sûr bien
sûr la surcharge d'icap hérité du nom de
son père n'a pas été facile elle qui
rêvait de s'occuper d'artistes de
comédien c'est pourtant très vite senti
à l'aise au front national
c'est un immense jeu de lumières musique
grandiose et à la tête de la troupe un
comédien hors pair
c'est ce qu'enseigne cesca public ce
qu'est une entrée en ça et c'est ce que
les micros et oui c'est tout mais depuis
longtemps une heure maintenant normal
mais depuis longtemps c'est pratique
pour nous quand même et puis il peut
rattraper un imprévu qui va pas c'est
quelqu'un il ya un truc qui va pas
qu'ils se débranche bacha il va
rattraper l'imprévu il va pas jeter le
micro et se marrer dire on s'est
terminée là il va y avoir attrapé
l'imprévu comme un artiste le ferai
champéry yann le pen reconnaît à son
père un grand talent d'artiste mais elle
le rejoint surtout sur un autre terrain
vous partagiez magath que les idées de
votre père vous affirmez jeu toujours
mais j'ai toujours partagé c'est mon
père bien sûr toujours et je suis venu
seul c'est pas lui qui magma imposé dire
que moi j'étais un peu baba cool quand
j'étais tout en ayant décidé de le pen
j'ai toujours eu les idées de le pen
et voilà comment elle met en scène les
idées de son père le discours de jean
marie le pen clôture les deux jours de
la convention du front national la salle
est pleine à craquer pour la chauffer le
clip de yann est diffusée aux premières
loges
jany le pen la femme du président et
apparemment le film lui plaît beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
jean-marie le pen fait son entrée sur
une musique au titre symbolique la quête
du paradis de vangelis
[Applaudissements]
yann est pour le moins ému
[Musique]
sur scène jean marie le pen va saluer
solennellement son public pendant plus
de cinq minutes
du grand spectacle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quelques jours plus tard nous avons
rendez vous avec jean marie le pen
devant le domicile de son épouse à rueil
malmaison
nous devions monter avec lui dans sa
voiture et l'accompagner jusqu'au siège
du fn seulement voilà il n'est pas un
homme d'humeur égale et ce qui lui
convient un jour peut subitement lagacé
lendemain notre équipe ce matin là va en
faire les frais
vous avez déjà testé à quoi ça cause
on est d'accord enfin vous n'allez pas
monté dans ma voiture et à tout moment
vous êtes monté une fois ça vous a donné
une prise de vue en voiture vous eussiez
sait s'il vous plaît non mais vous
commencez à me casser les pieds je dis
franchement voilà je vais le dire
direction le sais j'en ai marre et donc
commencer des choses qu est ce que vous
allez faire là vous lui avez volé vous
mettez vous n'avez pas besoin de
m'interroger dans ma voiture que c'est
que ça si vous avez ça à savoir ce que
j'ai à dire vous prenez n'importe quand
et pas dans ma voiture vous m'imposer et
des commandes et servitude
je vous ai donné une fois la chance et
vous êtes le seul qui j'ai permis de
monter dans ma voiture pour tourner non
mais pas une fois pas deux fois pas
trois fois non
[Musique]
on
après cet incident jean-marie le pen
refusera que l'on poursuive notre
tournage dans les coulisses de sa
campagne
[Musique]
pour sa dernière course à l'elysée cet
homme habitué aux provocations
réussira-t-il à réitérer la surprise du
21 avril 2002 qui l'avait vu accéder au
second tour
jean marie le pen est aujourd'hui
crédité de 14% dans les sondages
les quatre points de plus qu'en 2002 à
la même période